vision API can be used to extract  information from images such as labels  texts landmarks and more let's see how  to use version AP with c-sharp  first make sure vision a pay is enabled  in your project and a service account  exist to make API calls both are  explained in the cobweb in the video  notes in cloud shell let's create a  simple dotnet console app and add vision  API nougat package to the project open  the online call editor and navigate to  program dot C S we will perform text  detection on this image first reference  vision API library and create an image  editor client  point to the image and call detect text  method and print out the text now run  the app there you go you just perform  text detection using the vision API